it's not your typical london one bed
it's
amazing
what's he like
the man who built this
he interviews prospective tenants
personally
we need to find the right fit
but perhaps we've found her
my houses make demands of people the
housekeeper system gathers data from
whoever lives a full gate street to
improve the user experience
living in a different way a different
place i think it'll help are you sure
about this
why wouldn't i be
how are you finding it here the house
and i are a good match for each other
and the man who built it could you be a
good match for each other
emma i will love you forever
here's emma
do you know anything about the young
woman who lived here before
emma matthews
how well did you know her
yeah she looks just like you
same eyes same jawline you look like her
this has hallmarks of repetition
compulsion acting out the same
psychodrama with new players allotted
the same role
we have these rules for a reason they
are there to help us do the right thing
even when it's hard we just objects to
be replaced whenever we do something you
don't like
i need to understand how this relates to
me and to emma you agree to live here
under certain words your wife life just
doesn't work like that let me make it
work like that if it is a pattern it may
not be over
[Music]
hello
for
somebody's taking my place
you